magnus wants to win it or take it to toy
breaks and the match has started here we
go david yeah the tournament tournament
all hinges on this game now the first
game of this final day has begun and
it's the reti opening magnus brings his
night out on the first move with white
and pragmata reacting classical fashion
black occupies the center with the pawn
and magnus taking a quieter approach
just getting ready to fianchetto his
bishop prague continuing his strategy of
throwing those pawns forward and this is
still very standard stuff
magnus throughout the uh event here
throughout the fgx crypto cup he has
started a bit slowly this is something
we were discussing uh before the show
and having the white pieces should help
with that uh normally it's easier to
kind of start well uh get a good opening
get a good start to the day when you
have white but prague he's
been very aggressive in general with
both colors right what do you guys think
of this opening choice uh from magnus
yeah
a wise opening choice
i mean i i when you're playing someone
so young like prague you probably don't
want to jewel them with cutting-edge
fury
um because they're going to be very well
prepared for that and i feel like prague
might have better cutting-edge fairy
than magnus so he's trying to take him
into what is now a reverse gruntfield
opening
and just take him into a position where
he can get a game and play but prague at
the moment playing extremely quickly as
well and we see some standard moves on
the board here
with quite a solid start to the game so
far
and as you mentioned simon this position
could arise from the grunfeld defense
with colours reversed here white has an
extra tempo
compared to that opening because you
start
with the first move
but uh prague one thing i will say
against the grunfeld he's had a lot of
success using this system so again with
colors reversed with the white pieces he
likes to make this exchange that's just
happened in the center he's like he
likes to bring his bishop out if we kind
of rewind a couple of months back when
prague played this fantastic game
against jordan van forest with all these
sacrifices all these spectacular tactics
and he won
that was the grenfell prague had white
and it was this exact position just with
reverse colours so
he's just using that pattern recognition
he realizes what type of position he
likes where he's had success and he's
trying to
kind of replicate that despite the fact
he's got black here in this game and
that's quite clever such a key idea that
i think i mean
everyone at home should be doing that as
well you've got to recognize what kind
of positions you enjoy playing
and when i'm saying positions mainly
like middle game positions and you want
to always try to steer
the game into
things that you're favorable playing
whether that's a tactical battle or
certain pawn structures
as we're seeing prague do here because
you're going to play better in positions
you're comfortable with right so and
i'm just checking the database and i can
actually see that pregnant has played
this before with the black pieces in
fact not that long ago in the norway
chess not the big tournament but the
open tournament and there he played
against the bulgarian grand master and
it was a draw so magnus now has a choice
you know what's he going to do with the
night capture nights
trade nights or just move the night back
yeah white's knight in the center of the
board has that big decision to make i
think the most popular move or at least
the move with the best reputation uh up
until recently was to retreat this night
but maybe magnus had it in mind that
prague loves those types of positions so
instead he's swapped off his set of
pieces heading closer to an end game and
uh now white is going to try and open up
the diagonal for his light squared
bishop white slight square bishop in
front of his king he's the key piece
here it's staring against black center
from afar black's pawn center there if
it can stay intact will ensure pregnant
under good long term chances but if
magnus can break open the center
maybe start using his poor majority on
this left side of the board then
white will be doing well so it's kind of
double double-edged both sides have
reasons to be happy white's queen now
indirectly attacking black's dark
squared bishop on this sea lion
and uh yeah this game i guess it will
just be about understanding the next uh
the next handful of moves at least where
to put the pieces how to continue
developing especially from the black
side black's king needs to get to safety
yeah
and white already has a threat on the
board to play pawn takes pawn and that
is why pragnanda simply moves his queen
protects the bishop
and they're still following that game
that i referenced earlier and in that
game white actually developed the dark
squared bishop out to g5 to pin the
knight
magnus said he was just taking a sip of
water but then he kind of paused when he
saw this last move from uh pregnant
ander
okay he's laughing again now
by this point we're used to this for
magnus
seems to be a daily occurrence
but uh there's some calculation to be
done because this last move
to me initially it looked like it was
impossible
just because there are some tactics now
to calculate magnus looking away
laughing not entirely focused
but
if we just jump into the position
just while magnus kind of recomposes
himself uh you guys mentioned there's a
threat
potentially along the c file if you
trade off a set of pawns in the center
now if you make this trade you can uh at
least if you're new to this position
which i pretty much am at this moment uh
you can push this pawn forward asking
this black bishop a question it's
defended by its queen but it needs to
move now being attacked by pawn if the
bishop moves out the way white has a
nasty check
and suddenly the black king in a bit of
trouble
and i'm just wondering what pragnanda's
idea would be here the black rook in the
corner will fall off once black meets
that check to his king
and uh if we go back a couple of moves
um you could step forward with the
bishop yeah maybe the
rook in the corner just by the speed
with which prague has played and also
the fact that you mentioned he's played
it before jovanka means that clearly
black isn't losing here otherwise the
evaluation bar would have shot up but uh
still some calculation to be done for
magnus if he hasn't studied this
a check now i guess would be met by a
queen block and if white's queen
captures the rook in the corner
at the very least black could do the
same catch a white rook in the corner of
the board maybe you could also castle
the black king and argue that the white
queen is trapped next move black's
bishop will move out the way and
for example if white
i don't know pushers are pawn this
bishop might move out the way and this
queen is a goner
so really complicated stuff already it's
really sharp stuff
the players definitely uh especially
prague here looks well prepared in the
opening magnus decided if we go back to
the game position not to enter any murky
complications that's wise prague is
clearly ready for uh anything messy
that appears on the board so magnus just
develops his pieces he'll develop this
knight next he'll develop this bishop
connect his rooks and the game will go
on i'm expecting prague now to castle
with haste
and uh yeah in the ballots
and magnus laughing again we did hear
rumors yesterday there is a podcast he's
listening to probably one of his
favorite podcasts must be a funny one
and it was interesting right hearing
from lavon before the start of today
saying that it's more enjoyable because
he can listen to music and it's very
we're not used to this when seeing chess
players smiling laughing but maybe this
simply is the new life when it comes to
online chess
because obviously you can listen to
whatever you want
yeah
i mean it's quite refreshing to see
someone enjoying themselves but at the
same time as i think this works on
online chess because the two players do
have a computer because it would be
incredibly distracting if you were
playing over the board chess and you
know someone had their headsets and it
was like bopping away
or like laughing themselves silly you
know i would be like
come on
[Laughter]
get serious but then again i like this
kind of move towards you know i don't
see why chess has to be so introverted i
mean it could be super extroverted as
well involving as many people as
possible and uh we do see magnus develop
the dark squared bishop
and i just want to introduce
our competition our quiz of the day
it's a cool one it is a very cool one
because today we are asking for you to
caption this picture yeah and uh maybe
we can put it up on the screen we have
to get that picture up oh there it is
yes and uh there we see young pregnant
yesterday's unfortunate moment and we
asking caption this you don't need to
edit the picture just caption say put in
your caption into the tweet and remember
to use the hashtag chess champs and uh
can't wait to read out your answer the
best caption will win one year's chess
24 subscription
oh i'm looking forward to this our
creative viewers
what will you find as a creative caption
to that prank picture go ahead and join
the competition for one year chess 24
premium
all right we have some moves in this
dramatic game david yeah and prague is
just following conventional wisdom here
normally in this type of position when
there's no direct tactics anymore
there's no big attacks yet
it's just a wise to improve your worst
place peace and that black light square
bishop was doing nothing sad at home and
therefore it's come out and magnus
reacts by putting his knight on the side
of the board we normally say don't do
this knights are terrible on the side of
the board but it's actually an outpost
this white knight can't ever get kicked
away by a black pawn therefore it stands
relatively well also putting some big
pressure on black's dark square bishop
so that dark sky bishop will now most
likely take a step back
we'll retreat and it's again it's just
about who can place their pieces better
i love what both sides have done with
their pieces sent nicely centralized on
all on active squares next both sides
will try and bring their rooks into the
game
and it does feel like this is the calm
before the storm
whose position do you prefer um simon
ivanka
to me
i mean i'd happily take both sides here
yeah i i think both players just playing
good moves at the moment uh you can't
afford anything that's being done um i
kind of like what magnus has done to to
get a position which is less theoretical
and more about the plans i think he's
going to try to use it you know that
experience he's got and try not to make
it too tactical
at the moment um you know maybe later on
we'll see that but prague of course um
has played very well he's got a very
strong center his pawns are doing a good
job he's got all his pieces developed so
it's probably an equal position but if
you look at most of magnus's games that
just doesn't bother him at all
when he's got the white pieces he often
goes to equal positions even sometimes
he will go for slightly worse positions
because he knows the plans and he's more
comfortable in those types of structures
i would kind of like to know what he's
listening to i think someone said a
norwegian comedy show i don't know if
that's an oxymoron we mentioned that
just if i get in trouble now
nope it's all gone quiet okay um so i
don't know what what what what is good
comedy shows i'd like to know but
obviously something something is making
him laugh a lot i mean but it amazes me
because
you know i've done a lot of streaming uh
a lot of other stuff and when i'm
playing chess
i can't have any distractions i mean i
can put some music on but i can't listen
to a podcast
and understand what they're saying and
laugh about that podcast and play a good
game of chess it just it just bewilders
me that he's able to do that how's he
able to do two things like that i think
i find it i find it like quite you know
miraculous really i mean could you could
you do that david could you listen to
like i don't know a comedy podcast and
play and play great level chess at the
same time it's it's amazing really it's
incredible anyone who knows me knows i
can't multitask
yeah i couldn't do it i guess it's maybe
similar to um if you imagine in
especially in the us they have chess in
the parks and all these hustlers in
washington square park and uh they're
just kind of chatting while they play
trying to distract the opponent and
kind of giving that banter back and
forth
and yeah i guess some players have grown
up with that
most people grow up where chess is kind
of a silent game in a big tournament
hall and you can't distract your
opponent but clearly this is adding a
new dimension um this esports
arena and magnus seems to be thriving on
it meanwhile a trade of dark square
bishops and white rooks are starting to
gravitate towards the center white's
rooks need to be improved the black
rooks need to be improved
uh black's queen also feeling a bit
uncomfortable i'm expecting her to
run away at some point in the next few
turns
okay there we go pregnant puts his queen
back on a nice safe square i still like
black's pawn center to be honest this
kind of triangle formation that black
has in the middle of the board with his
pawns
rock solid how do you ever break those
down
prague does not look
too concerned either he looks pretty
content with how the opening has gone
yeah
i mean it does look
like prague's position is pretty solid
but i have to say i'm still loving
white's position i just think that
his position especially when you bear in
mind the match situation
he just needs to tie the rapid portion i
think this is also quite nice for him
you know he has the choice i like
i think this move is actually maybe
i was gonna say i like it but then i
stopped and i was like hang on a second
think a bit deep deeply um i mean it's
quite a committal move actually because
uh
i mean yes it reinforces the center but
also there's a lot of tension on the
board you know white always has the
possibility of capturing the pawn maybe
black can also capture the porn as well
and uh prague switching sides and he's
put his rook on the b line now if you
like these types of positions ivanka you
should play the grenfell defense
you get these types of positions uh on a
regular basis oh really uh yeah i mean
this is still a grunfeld in in nature
with the pawn structure with the pieces
white uh magnus here he's borrowing all
of the kind of ideas from that opening
and now stepping forward with the white
queen white's queen wants to actually go
to the left side of the board start
harassing that lonely black bishop black
bishop out there it's actually i praised
him putting it there a few moves ago but
it is actually a bit of a target for
white's queen and knight
so uh prague has to guard against that
potential threat
yeah sorry simon no i i would have
thought magnus would be very comfortable
actually just the way this has gone i
mean i think it's kind of a big
advantage of magnus having the white
pieces in this first game because he's
been as you mentioned very fragile
in the first game he lost the hands he
lost to yesterday he got smashed by
farouza he's lost a lot of the first
rounds and
duda and like having white means he can
control the way the game goes so he
wanted this position from move one he's
got what he wants and that's that's uh
you know if we compare it to his cara
khan
in the first game yesterday he certainly
didn't want that position we all know
the caracane is a rubbish opening
[Laughter]
i wanted to just look at you there
i joke it's not a rubbish open it's a
fantastic opening and if you want to
learn it then ivanka's got some
fantastic books on it but he's got a
kind of position he wants and i i that
is very important uh just to get safely
into the match and let's remember prague
has to win in the four games he can't go
to the the playoff if he wants to win
the whole thing i mean what a story
that'd be though i mean
you know i i i'm a bit sick of magnus
winning everything unless you know he
wins everything let's just let prague
have a chance well we know it'll be a
great story yeah
and we did hear from tanya it was 50 50
with the spectators she talked to and
we're going to go back to tanya in
miami what is the mood and the vibe like
now tanya that the match has started
it's just such a great atmosphere here
kaya the players are loving it
everyone who's here for this symbol
they're talking about all the action
that's going on on this one big matchup
and i've got a magnus supporter and a
prague supporter here with me
roy and grant joining us hey guys how
are you doing we are doing amazing thank
you are you having fun with your chess
weekend in miami yeah it's been great
it's been great
and i mean this matchup right given our
tournament the way it's shaped up we
could not have asked for a better final
definitely i'm i'm definitely rooting
for perk today
he has done an amazing job like in the
beginning he fumbled a little bit last
two games but then i'm definitely sure
today you're gonna come back bounce back
big big moment for prague because if he
wins this he wins the match what do you
think it's going to take for him to
strike down magnus
i think it's just the time pressure if
he maintains his like nerves and
i think he's gonna he gonna do great
and he has done it before against magnus
so
i'm definitely looking for it
all right and of course it's hard to bet
against magnus now grant what do you
think is going to happen today
right so obviously i think uh you know
prague kind of showed how strong he was
in the first that first time he played
magnus and then beat him in the blitz
round but uh then we saw magnus beat him
again right and so i think that's kind
of how magnus is like once you beat him
once he never forgets it and then he
just presses on and so i think he's
going to come out probably with the
catalan and we'll see how prague handles
it but
yeah it should be a great match i'm
looking forward to it why do you like
magnus's play so much um because he
really
he has like very strong strengths i
think in certain openings like you've
seen him dominate with the catalan all
you know all year pretty much i think
this has been kind of a new trend of his
but also he's not afraid to just
completely
come at you with something that you
don't have prep for cause like also
magnus knows that people have prep
against him in the strongest opening so
he likes to blindside a lot and that's
what he's good at he's good at taking
you in the water and uh when you don't
know how to swim so
kyle lots of panditry on here
discussions on how the opening's going
it's going to be all about who puts the
pressure first and gets that first blow
that first win in the match back to you
guys in the studio oh yeah thank you
tanya and well some chess fans that
definitely know what they're talking
about i've been following magnus a lot
and his mind is uh getting this game
into that
water where he's comfortable he's
definitely gonna be very comfortable
this is his style of game this is his uh
this is kind of classic magnus um i've
got a praise grant there that we heard
from because he said magnus has been
dominating with the catalan and um this
is kind of a catalan opening or at least
a kind of a cousin variation to the
catalan but it's got all those
characteristics it's all about white
slight square bishop look how it
controls this whole long diagonal very
typical of that opening and white has
some pressure
it looks very balanced especially the
pawn structure which is almost
symmetrical but white's pieces are
slightly more centralized with the rooks
now the white queen better place than
the black queen slightly superior
bishops
it's all about whether pride can
neutralize
the initiative that magnus wants to whip
up and okay prague takes the time out to
push a pawn
simon you're the master of pushing a
harry potter is that timid or is that i
found it a bit strange i thought he
could have re-routed the knight maybe to
the queen side there while he has the
opportunity to
i mean i i i know if you look at the
pieces on the side of the board they
might be key to this position you've got
white's knight on the edge of the board
and knights on the side of the board are
generally quite bad but it's it's it's
kind of a great piece pointing at
black's weak pawn
um and you've got black's bishop on the
edge of the board which hasn't got a
very good range but it is also pointing
at white's pawn
and i was thinking black maybe missed an
opportunity to swap his knight off for
that night but it's still a very solid
position and i think with that move that
proud play just pushing uh the harry
porn he's just saying i you know i'm
going to be patient in this game there's
no rush i i'm going to keep my call i
think my position is absolutely fine um
i don't need to panic come on magnus i
you can't grind me i'm the prague um i
think that's basically what you're
saying right i mean he's just you know
confidently playing decent moves there
yeah solid move there from black just
defending this pawn i guess white had a
threat maybe of entering the black camp
with his rook uh very nasty threat now
against the bishop the bishop is almost
trapped it only has one safe square has
to retreat challenging off against
white's very strong bishop and uh the
reason that black has uh prague here put
his rook on the square because now he
defends this pawn as you mentioned simon
it's a target for white tonight but for
now it all clings together and uh blacks
knight also doing a good job on this
square for now of stopping white rook
entering the seventh rank this square is
covered by black's knight and i don't
think this would achieve an enormous
amount for magnus so
right now it's just about
how can white improve his pieces as you
mentioned the knight looks
good in a wave right now the white queen
is very flexible but she is tied down to
defending the pawn in front of her
white's rooks beautifully placed doubled
up on the d-file
but what do you do with them
and you definitely don't really want to
touch the white bishop it's a great
piece anyway
so yeah here is just about instinct and
kind of when to go for it does magnus go
for it now maybe by bringing his rook in
would you consider like pushing your
king side pawns here yeah i mean like h3
and g4 i mean because you pointed out
all the white's pieces are quite nicely
positioned i mean i do think what matt
white has to be a little bit better here
because he's got that open file totally
under his control with both of his works
you know two rooks on an open file is an
ideal scenario while black's works are
not as good um i also prefer his bishop
slightly but what does he do what does
he do next right as you pointed out it's
not so easy to find a plan and we can
see that prague's waiting so when your
opponent is clearly waiting with a move
like harry six you know you've got a bit
more time so i might consider doing
something a little bit weird on the king
side here if i was playing white um
you know
potentially it's a bit of a weird plan
but maybe i like this move in general at
least you have a safe square for your
king just in case there's any back rank
checks later on you also stop the black
knight from ever jumping into your half
of the board it's kind of a useful move
it's maybe not the most direct but very
useful and you throw the move back to
your opponent i like it yeah i like it
for those reasons as well uh david
and uh
yeah such a exciting position so many
things brewing in the future
and uh
whilst the players are thinking well
can i read out some of my captions
already yeah yeah i mean there's been
fantastic response and you guys
are really knocking out of the ball when
it comes to your captions so we are
asking everyone at home to kind of
caption this picture of prague that he
is
poor prague and uh the best caption wins
one year subscription of chess 24
premium a membership and uh iron man
says silence of the champs
very good
and uh hisham says
is magnus laughing at my move
and ashish kumar saying says chess will
speak for itself oh
nice one very nice
keep them coming remember to tweet your
answers using the hashtag chess champs
yeah
very nice
all right
chess will speak for itself and that is
what prague needs today he needs to win
it and the rapid portion
he has uh more time on the clock than
magnus carlson ticking down under eight
minutes now magnus made a move with his
rook
anything changing at all
at least there's a threat in the
position that white rook is attacking
black's bishop on the sixth rank so that
bishop i would have thought needs to
move the fact that prague paused means
that there's actually an alternative one
that i missed originally but i'm not
sure whether he wants to go for this or
not black does have a bit of a sneaky
night jump into the center potentially
uh but the fact that prague has spent
one minute now when dropping back
black's bishop looks very solid
uh it's a bit concerning for me either
he's going to go for something very
strong or he's maybe overthinking things
and
what do we think here maybe if we jump
in it could be a critical moment now
right now this bishop is attacked simon
do you have any uh suggestions here yeah
i mean i i think your bishop dropping
back just looks very sensible but you've
got the night jump and you've also got
the weird a weird rook move haven't you
tried trying to get rid of one of
white's one of white's rooks because
white's rooks are
really the only thing that might be
giving white and advantage this one or
even rook b1 i was thinking oh wow could
could
be playable um
i just want to swap off i just make sure
i'm not black
i just want to swap off a rook right
and i'm saying that very slowly now
because it's sort of like did i
but it looks all right but but maybe
this is what he's thinking of you know
because obviously you want to get rid of
your opponent's best pieces one of
white's best pieces his brooks he's gone
further sensible bishop b7 no butch must
be okay as well did cost him a couple of
minutes i like this one simon uh just to
explain to the viewers um you're just
pinning white on this first rank and
you're kind of deflecting away this
white rook so it looks like black's
giving up a piece but when the rook's
deflected and distracted away its other
rook drops and this looks very balanced
very equal this type of position so
maybe a small
opportunity there for prague to
completely
neutralize white's pressure but instead
yeah he did play the most obvious one
and the very solid bishop retreat and uh
if the bishops disappear from the board
maybe prague will breathe a sigh of
relief still some pressure though some
awkward pressure on this pawn it's just
about whether white's knight is well
placed or misplaced i feel
uh also now that the black bishop's gone
away white has no pressure on this guy
so maybe the white queen is free to kind
of jump into the center or maybe even
jump the other way
and white will be quite active over the
next few moves yeah and uh just to kind
of mention that there is a pressing
threat in this position pragnanda is
threatening to play bishop takes bishop
and after king takes bishop the knight
will jump forward to the e4 square
forking the queen and the rook so you
need to do something about that
and that is why magnus you know he kind
of centralizes his queen i'm a little
bit surprised by that particular
maneuver because i actually thought the
queen would jump two squares forward to
the e5 square because you know
looks much more aggressive yeah um i i
agree i was just looking in one of these
two directions um you have mentioned in
the past you've anchored that this is
kind of the golder lock square where
it's just kind of perfect it's not too
hot not too cold you can go in any
direction
a bit later on so very flexible square
from magnus choices square for his queen
and the bishops have left the board so
now it's just about the heavy pieces
plus these sets of knights white's
knight on the edge of the board has this
threat of capturing a pawn now and
prague needs to defend against it black
is still rock solid but
i'm just worried he's too passive
he's got to be a bit careful here maybe
it's time to sort of try to activate his
queen here possibly um i mean i agree
with you if you look at white's pieces
white still has control of the open file
white has pressure with his queen and
his knight so all the white's pieces are
are doing something uh and i'm trying to
work out why again the evaluation bar it
doesn't always tell the full side of the
story i mean maybe this is the
evaluation bar if black finds a series
of very accurate moves because otherwise
you know he's going to feel the pressure
here but if i was black i'd be looking
at ways to try and get some activity so
i'm wondering if i can sort of use my
queen to check and then either offer a
queen or maybe even offer a queen
exchange on the next move possibly uh
here or into this oh yeah here maybe
gotta be careful it's brook check but i
think it's i think it's so i think it's
okay
hits the black king and after a rook
trade um maybe you can run something
okay but it's a bit scary if your rook
gets deflected away then uh you would
lose the black queen i mean tactics i
suppose this is a way that you know it
if you can swap the queens get your rook
into the game you get active well okay
he's gone for another queen move a bit
more passive than this one
playing very defensively prague um i
guess there is one active idea maybe he
wants to go for this white knight this
white knight again
is it a strength is it a weakness it's
unclear at the moment
and he's holding everything together the
more i look at it the more i think it's
quite okay
and
yeah right now i don't really see a way
for magnus to take advantage again i'm
always looking for tactics now that
you've mentioned this rook check for
example knight takes pawn is this
possible because after the queen
recaptures can
white
give a check now this looks very scary
because again if the black rook kind of
moves away and captures suddenly after a
bunch of trades the black queen will be
kind of free of charge just captured
this uh
suddenly it's getting sharp
it looks good that line it
yeah
knight takes pawn knight is porn yeah i
mean uh maybe there are tactics on the
board for example black's knight could
jump into the center of the board
breaking the connection between the two
white rooks
giving itself up but uh if it's captured
then this white rook would fall it's
getting really sharp now yeah i mean
there's all sorts of tricks and both
players under five minutes so if we go
back to the current position knight
takes pawn may be possible but a lot of
calculation will be required that's why
magnus has slowed down
it's quite funny i think a lot of people
don't realize that chess positions
there's so much going on under the
surface right i mean it's they're like
you call them icebergs right you've got
the iceberg and then underneath the the
ocean you've got this massive bottom of
the iceberg and even in positions like
this which kind of seem fairly
straightforward
as in
symmetrical pawn structure doesn't seem
like anyone's attacking you've got these
always these little tactics and they're
really what kind of drives the position
and um you know you've got to be so
aware of these mini tactics always uh i
didn't see that knight takes pawn even
though we've been looking at the rook
check um and then the other night coming
in these are very deep tactics and a
seemingly simple position
just shows you how complex chess can be
yeah
magnus thinking for more than two
minutes now one game has finished in the
arena it's a draw between levon and
alireza ferruga and lavon let's hear it
from him after that first game
this ended up being a defensive battle
to begin the day oh yeah i i completely
forgot about knight d4 and then i had to
watch out
those kind of games when you managed to
save a draw they may give a good feeling
or you're a little bit frustrated that
you ended up in the position to begin
with
i didn't think it was so bad i thought
it was a tiny bit worse for me but
should be a troll generally good luck
thank you
wow pick mine
the fans are inside the miami arena and
they have some cool tickets today to
watch this drama the spectators in the
arena sitting only a few
meters away
and the drama david is it starting in
this game now look at the bar i think it
is starting i according to the computer
at least magnus has made a mistake so we
said that this was possible the night
capture of a pawn and it holds together
with tricks uh if the black queen takes
the white knight actually pragnando will
lose uh due to the line we showed just a
few moments ago but
okay there we see stockfish the computer
says that black has one move to give a
significant advantage and it's a black
knight retreat and prague has played it
and he's turned it around of course he
played it david yeah you know
we're not surprised anymore pregnantly
always plays the best move when one is
much better than all the other
alternatives
yeah was it a difficult move to find
yeah they say that the most difficult
move in chess is always a backward night
move because you always want to be
looking forwards nights are so tricky
the black knight we showed it can
uh it could have jumped forward
attacking the white queen in two
different ways instead it steps back
attacking the white rook and magnus has
sacrificed a piece
if the white rook which was under attack
from the black knight if it had moved
away then it would have been safe for
black to win white's knight so magnus
he's trying just trying to get the
highest price possible for his piece
there so now he's two pawns up magnus
but his knight is about to drop doesn't
seem to be laughing anymore
after that little exchange of uh
moves there
so what is it about the position now
because magnus obviously made this uh
move what is it about the position now
that has him maybe not too optimistic
about it suddenly the stakes are much
higher on the board so we will most
likely see a scenario where black has an
extra knight but white has three pawns
in return and that's a significant
imbalance
white pawns if you look at them they're
not very far advanced they're not very
scary black's knight doesn't look great
right now but if it activates itself
black is essentially playing with a
whole extra piece so the stakes are
higher for magnus if he's not accurate
if he doesn't find any active counter
play he's just going to be a piece down
he's going to be suffering and he's
going to lose the game
it's up to prague now
to see whether he can take this white
knight off the board and go on to
convert that
material advantage
and he is given a check but he has to
take that knight and yes it's
disappeared off the board and uh prague
while he is in good chances to secure
the win magnus's hopes in saving the
draw probably lie in the fact that there
aren't that many pawns on the board
if all the pawns disappear and the
queens get traded off then it probably
will fizzle out into a draw
and of course remember the black king
it's not that safe yeah we see on the
screen magnus there he hesitated before
taking a pawn with the white queen just
for a few seconds it was the only move
on the board to stay in the game and now
he retreats and he's broken the pin if
you look at the black queen and the
diagonal she sits on white has a rook
white has a queen and white king all on
the same diagonal of the black queen
yeah it's
he's setting traps magnus carlsen he's
setting a similar trap to the one we
showed a bit earlier the most obvious
move in the position now for prague
would actually be a blunder so he's
hoping that prague picks up his knight
maybe we can show this on the board
we do have this material imbalance
black's knight is now long term going to
be facing off against three white pawns
everything else is level uh if black
moves the knight it looks like black is
winning with a fork a double attack but
white can use this continuous kind of
motif this tactic what can give a check
hitting the king and after a bunch of
exchanges here the black queen is no
longer protected so magnus has set this
trap trying to win the black queen we
won't see prague blunder of course if he
hadn't spotted this blunder then he
would have played this knight jump
immediately but his knight is required
to block the eighth rank maybe the black
queen should move
if the black queen moves you do set up
this threat
so where to go that's the question
there's a lot of tension on this
diagonal
magnus
is setting traps prague now down to
around two minutes needs to solve those
threats and okay he attacks this spawn
with his queen
but uh it is just attacking the pawn
though i mean it's not actually renewing
the threat of the knight attacking the
rook because of the same trick
and uh
yep this queen is still on the same
diagonal as the white queen so
uh okay how does magnus protect this
pawn though if he brings this rook up
the board as ivanka mentions this knight
uh this knight jump he does play this
move this would be met by a nasty check
same idea we showed earlier
so right now prague he has to fight
against the combined might of these
three pieces but they're not really
threatening anything
it's so tense i mean the computer might
favor black but if white kind of keeps
this bind if white maybe starts
maneuvering some pieces towards that
black king
who knows who knows here i'm surprised
magnus hasn't reacted though because i
don't know if he missed this or he kind
of got to this position by
i kind of stumbled into it i think he
must have just
he wouldn't have gone for this position
i mean i uh why why would the white
pieces do you want to give away uh you
know you're basically allowing your
opponent winning chances uh because the
position is now so unbalanced you're
giving prague decent winning chances
he's got an extra piece at the end of
the day and
you know it's very likely at some point
white could lose another pawn because
those pawns are weak okay he's come all
the way back now so now he's trying to
bring his knight into the game i kind of
like that move it's quite a quite you
know you need to get your pieces rolling
and i like going into the corner of
queens because it just looks kind of
cool right uh you know you don't get a
chance to do that very often but his
knight will jump out um and this is this
is uh quite dangerous i feel for magnus
now i mean he loses with the white
pieces and you know if he does in round
one that's going to be a a real real
like uh upstart to the day
um
it's not that bad for him because of
course he's got his pawns and he's got
three pawns and he's got nice central
control but
still i was actually wondering about
this move on the last turn uh prague he
had this
uh he had this position he could have
dropped his queen back immediately maybe
it was even stronger
because this white pawn would be less
defended than it is in the game but
either way in the current position
massive threat on the board prague will
win if he gets this knight fork hitting
the queen and rook so magnus needs to do
something about it pressure on the world
champion lower on the clock as well
i i have to say i just saw a really good
answer to your tweet there and it was um
yeah i think it was it the i don't know
if it's this one but it was uh the
picture of prague and it says when you
realize you've got to play england on
board free for india
i thought that is
we have the main man sitting next to us
we got the gold medal so uh
i didn't play prank though
wow i mean but that that was a that was
an awesome tweet yeah that must be a
contender already definitely that one
but
who won seven out of eight games in the
olympia that's just crazy one draw seven
wins insane
yeah and meanwhile the queens are off
the board in this game so that is one
step closer to end his end goal here
prague that black knight now can finally
enter the fray into the action and
white's pawns still don't look great
especially those two pawns on the left
side for white they are isolated they
are potentially weak you mentioned it
simon if one of those pawns drops off
black is going to win this game so black
just needs to coordinate i think the key
here as well is keeping black's a pawn
intact if black can keep the a pawn
alive it's a potential winner in the end
game it might march down the board but
if that black pawn falls then
i don't know black's two remaining pawns
on the other flank it won't probably be
enough for victory it's somewhere
between a draw and a win here but it's
all about black yeah but the thing is
though black's rooks are really active
and black's knight is also well placed
as well
and i i like what magnus is doing you
know he's simply saying okay
let's just uh mobilize my extra pawns in
the middle of the board
yeah i mean surely now it's time for
black to get his rooks activated
and um you know that the sea pawn which
is the one next to the white rook looks
looks like a natural target for black to
me
um you know you want to find targets and
attack them when you're playing chess
and black has a and here he goes he's
piling on the pressure to that pawn and
i'm wondering how on earth does white
actually guard that pawn i think he
forgets it so he is going on defensive
but prague plays this night move
immediately in our words that is a i'd
love that move because that night if it
sits in front of that pawn you're really
suffocating the rook and i i mean you're
not going to really get better chances
of beating the world champion than a
position like this i mean this is you
know there's a lot of work to do but
prague has a great chance here and what
a start to the today's story would be if
he manages to win with black in round
one
wow the trend might continue magnus just
a slow starter
and he had a great position the world
champion from the
from the opening early middle game and
then prague just turned it around prague
was just tactically sharp at that one
kind of crucial moment when everything
was happening and this is the result
black has just a beautiful end game i
think if colours were reversed here if
magnus had the black pieces it would
just be game over he would win this one
so it's just about prague's endgame
technique now which we've seen is very
very good
and okay white meanwhile centralized
this is king the move you mentioned
simon that knight is threatening to jump
and attack both whatever what if you go
a6 here
i mean i'm just saying if you move the
pawn forwards one square look how
embarrassed that rook is but i guess
black can't move either but it just
seems like you know we can maybe show it
on the board and look at the rook in
front of that pawn it has no squares it
can ever move to and i'm moving that
pawn to take away a square uh i mean
that that's a very tempting move to play
i don't know but you've got to think how
you improve the position after this move
and he's played it he's played it um but
how do you now improve because you can't
also move the black rooks as well
he's going to defend this pawn i guess
with his rook and then he'll move the
knight out the way at the right moment
uh he will threaten at some point to
start jumping and maybe trying to trap
this rook if white isn't careful i think
he is going to go for your plan uh simon
of trapping the rook maybe this way go
go backwards and then uh just push the a
pawn forward and just keep on
embarrassing that
rook yeah exactly if there's a rook on
the edge of the board it looks it looks
horrendous for white this position
really bad
not just bad but really bad i i would
say i mean you know you're you're
probably going to win the sea pawn as
well at the right moment
and then you really just to piece up
aren't you and
look what prague is doing you know he's
like yeah you know i'm not gonna rush
with that plan i'm going to bring in my
king and so that's why
magnus quickly moves the rook over and
says no
that piece is not coming to the action
at the very least here prague can just
retreat his knight hitting this rook and
when the rook moves he can bring his
other knight into the game hitting this
rook hitting this pawn he's going to win
this pawn and it's just about whether
magnus here can activate his rooks the
white rooks want to kind of enter the
seventh rank and start going for black's
two weaknesses uh the kind of pawns that
have been abandoned on the king side so
maybe still some hope for magnus if he
can get his rooks active but to me it
just seems like if this pawn drops and
then maybe this one drops afterwards it
should eventually be winning i love
prague's move though why rush
with this plan this plan is there
forever first he defends the seventh
rank and uh if you defend all your
weaknesses what's white gonna do magnus
loves fixing pawns uh he's he's won the
connect four game here uh for sure but
the rest of his position is just falling
apart at the right moment black he does
it now black will just step back
attacking this rook the rook's going to
move the black knight is going to hit
this rook hit the pawn and things are
going to start falling oh
magnus also ticking under the minute on
the clock now in this dramatic first
game in the match
could prague take
the lead in this match that will decide
the winner of the ftx crypto cup look at
that picture the 17 year old head to
head with the world number one in an
intense fight but he doesn't seem
to be put up by uh by this or any nerves
nothing prague just playing his best
chess as always yeah and his killer
instinct has been good in general prague
normally when he gets the advantage he
converts it just okay barring that uh
disastrous game yesterday uh in the tie
breaks but yeah whenever prague has the
advantage
yeah he nearly never slips up i think
that's what sets him apart from the rest
of this young generation
okay magnus centralizes one rook
so okay let's let's say you're you're
the captain of a chess team
okay you can pick one indian player goo
cash or crack
you've got to decide in five seconds
or prague you only get one of them
prague prank it's because he's beaten
mean
uh
good cash okay right i i don't know how
do you get ready
and you've got so many now uh brilliant
brilliant young players we have a pawn
being won here though and now it's
it's there's
i think there's still quite a bit of
work to do here but as you said david
black's a pawn is so important um and
it might sort of revolve around whether
black can win white's pawn on the side
of the board and queen his pawn
um because those you know white has
those pawns coming out the board um it's
not easy to win this one yeah still a
lot of work to be done he's taken some
of the risk out uh prague by swapping
one set of rooks but he's also maybe
minimized his winning chances because
there's less material on the board so
there's always that imbalance it's
always that kind of judgment call do you
swap pieces kind of reduce the chance
that you come under attack but also
reduce the chance that you have enough
kind of firepower later in the game
and uh oh the lights went off behind
them really dark in the studio and
lightning there almost but uh white is
stepping forward on one flank those
white pawns scary the four versus two
advantage white has on the right half
but they will be dealt with uh
quite easily by the black king and the
black pieces magnus he's just trying to
control that black knight if that black
knight somehow attacks that lonely white
a pawn
i think it's going to be game over it's
uh so close now big question here for
prague is you know is it good idea for
him to trade off rooks because okay we
see
magnus give a check to the rook but it
is possible for the rook to come down to
the third row and give a check and
attack the pawn and force the rooks off
the board yeah it's magnus's move though
he might stop that idea
he pushes his pawn forward yeah it's a
good question ivanka the rook's coming
off i guess i would only dream of going
for that as black if you can guarantee
that you're ahead in the race um
yeah that means just kings pawns and
even if there's a night on the board
it's it's so
close to all these races these pawn
races
i mean rook across two squares is very
tempting isn't it i mean uh
trying to it is very rough
yeah i mean because
i like this move you know because look
at the white rook doesn't have that many
squares
and uh well magnus is uh going on a huge
operation just to trade pawns
yeah prague just says okay i'm going to
control some squares
big threat now black just wanted to play
pawn takes pawn on this side of the
board if i have no black's terms it
would have been very strong
now this pawn trade i'm slightly
surprised prague went for that so
quickly he is low on uh on the clock
white has two pass pawns now in the
center of the board the e and f pawns
okay marching i sent prague is playing
very carefully which fits in so well
with this uh technique that when you're
playing with less time on the clock just
make a few moves over protect everything
and leave those critical moments for
when you've gathered more time on the
clock
there is a funny mistake that magnus
could play here if he puts his rook in
front of the pawn um we can see that
same idea i mean it's just
just i you know very unlikely to happen
but
it's kind of a move you would look at
but okay the king comes in now and i
guess magnus has just got to use his
pawns use his work to cause as many
problems as he can and he probably wants
to bring the king now in where the white
rook is and prague on the offensive
and uh prank's going to pick up another
pawn here isn't he probably at some
point i think he's got to be careful
there's a threat to push white's f pawn
forward if white's pawn steps forward
and attacks the black knight the black
knight is actually pinned and the white
king also going towards that black
knight so
prague most likely he will move his king
that was an interesting opportunity
actually on the last move prague could
have forced the rooks off by bringing
the black rook to the fifth rank he
could have done that and he didn't
choose to swap off he's just not good
enough time to work out whether trading
off the rooks will win for him
and uh could he have still done that
last i mean can you ask me can you go
back and try that again i mean he's got
to try to win this position he's kind of
hard to judge though with 15 seconds
left yeah such a big game the biggest
match of his career 10 he's gone under
10 seconds he's that and he has moved to
the g7 square so prague is so brave he
doesn't want the draw at all it's not
going to repeat anything and uh now i'm
guessing the knight is forced back
okay because you might have to repeat
the position in order to kind of put
your pieces back on their best squares
black's king is going away again
and uh which way you're going to go
either way you've repeated that position
this is the second time we've seen this
position also the second time we've seen
this position he's got to be really
careful now prague what he does
otherwise the position might repeat and
we'll see a draw if the position repeats
for that third time
oh he has to maybe offer a trade of
rooks he goes for it well played very i
mean
this is maybe a little bit of a
difference between prague and anish
don't be nasty to a niche but we saw
niche when he was playing uh against
magnus he was getting great positions
but he often took the draw um you know
because his time was going low but
prague is so brave
he's going for it and i think you've
gotta you've gotta go for it uh even if
it's
risky yeah there was a small missed
opportunity i think prague could have
forced the rooks off the board now
magnus has got his rook out white's rook
in the middle in the middle there looked
good but it needed to get out of the way
of his own pawns and now white central
pawns are going to start stepping
forward
suddenly it's not so easy at all for
prague
and uh these two white pawns are a bit
scary how do you stop their advance he's
very short time as well i mean
you might have to drop back the night or
something could be an idea uh just to
try to handle those pawns uh and also
you know there we go the knight does
drop back
and just wait and see what white's gonna
do next because the white rook is is is
quite passive and okay it comes this
square but now it might get harassed a
little bit
but white's pawns just about give him
enough compensation at the moment in the
center look at the clock times magnus
was down low on the clock just like
prague but he's played so quickly he's
built up a minute and a half now magnus
he's gained move game time with every
move
and okay if he wants now magnus can he
can repeat the position by going back to
the side i don't think he will
stop playing for a win i think he's
going to play on for the win you know
because the momentum has turned you know
look at the night the night and the rook
have not coordinated well meanwhile
white look at it it's a massive threat
big threat pushing the pawn of the check
is nearly checkmate here and uh actually
this is now
yeah getting very dangerous for prague i
mean especially with his time right
oh wow he's given up his knight he gave
the knight back he's going to secure the
draw most likely now prague but his
winning chances have gone he gave up the
black knight for two white pawns
his level pawns level material this game
should be heading towards the draw he
bailed out at the right time though he
lost control prague and really mature
decision with five seconds on his clock
he said okay
i can't lose this game of course the
wind would have been nice but i can't
lose and
yeah here we see a couple of checks
white's king steps back it's still white
with the advantage because white's king
and white's rook are slightly more
active than their counterparts but
what do you guys think yeah i think it's
just draw um this is the idea and switch
the rook across and uh if white tries to
if white grabs the pawn on h6 then the
rook can step forward and actually
start munching on the a pawn and that
will be a complete draw very very easy
yeah then again
magnus is the master squeezing out those
small advantages grinding out these end
games he's smiling there probably
because of something he's listening to
the position itself is not
too many chances for white
it looks like magnus on his screen he
was about to push his pawn his past pawn
forward in the middle of the board with
white
the problem is black's h-porn uh as your
ivanka mentions if it's allowed to live
it's gonna start running i expect prague
to start pushing his own passport now
just not enough material left to win
this one with best play unless there's a
big blunder
and there we go this pawn is a bit of a
distraction for white and maybe now
white can try to get his king to the
other side of the pawn uh to try and
force you know try and get some checks
available but of course this is a draw
with correct play
but you know from going from the
position prague had he's going to be
feeling the pressure quite intensely now
and magnus
now going for this pawn
and i would have thought this is
really not going to leave many more
chances okay this is a clever move
because now the white king will come in
and at least fort black force black's
king backwards at the right moment
though equally clever that's a nasty
trap if the white rook steps down two
squares and captures that black pawn
black's rook would have stepped up there
would have been a check and a skewer
across the board instead white steps
forward the king is checked back facts
rook is going to go away again and any
time the white king steps forward it
gets checked away that's the drawing
mechanism there
and it's so
so instructive how prag doesn't go
passive with his rook and get greedy
capturing pawns and allowing the white
king to reach the
the sixth row and instead every time the
king goes to the fifth row gets checked
away
and that's it draw
a dramatic game that ends up in a draw
they are tied after the first game in
this intense fight to win the ftx crypto
cup